Speaker 1: Joe Manchin, as much as or more
than Kirsten Cinema has become an obstacle
to Joe Biden's agenda.
There's really no other way to say it.
And I think he's enjoying it.
He seems to love going on the Sunday shows.
He seems to love having the amount of power
that he has because of this razor thin majority
50 50 with Kamala Harris as the tie breaking
vote in the Senate.
Well, if you can imagine anything more privileged,
I don't I don't really know what to call it.
Over the weekend, Senator Manchin emerged
from his yacht, called the almost heaven to
have some real conversations with West Virginia's,
who kayaked out to his yacht every single
day of the week.
This is just depressing on so many levels.
Let's take a listen.
This is Joe Manchin talking to West Virginians
from his yacht.
Speaker 4: Let me talk, if you can.
Where y'all from anybody from West Virginia,
where West Virginia?
We have a lot of West Virginians.
God bless you all.
Coming out of the gang, we're working hard.
We really are.
We're going to continue to in good faith.
I really want to get a good bill.
That's a balanced bill.
It's well done, and I know it won't be enough.
For some, it will be too much for others in
West Virginia.
You know, West Virginians, all the
Speaker 5: different views today.
There's a lot of poverty.
What are you going to do for the poor in West
Virginia?
Speaker 4: We're going to be working everything
we can to create good
Speaker 5: opportunities and we need to tax
the rich.
Speaker 4: Oh, I agree with that.
I definitely agree.
That's the one thing we should be doing is
fixing the tax code to everybody, pays their
fair share.
We should be also negotiating for lower drug
prices.
We should be doing all these things that make
them accountable.
I agree with you 1000 percent.
We're on the same page gang.
We really are here.
Speaker 1: I in my yacht and you on your kayaks.
Even though I'm getting in the way of all
these bills, we really are on the same page.
Dental, vision and hearing coverage.
Speaker 4: Medicare, that's a real opportunity
that we can.
Well, we have it here.
Let me just explain on that one.
We will get to that eventually.
But right now, we can't even take Kerry's
going to go broke in twenty twenty six.
Let us fix it.
It's not the time for the rich.
We're taxing the rich.
I agree we're going to make you rich and the
famous pay,
Unidentified: but I think you're going.
All right.
Speaker 1: So as you can tell, the conversation's
not really going to too far.
But of course, the imagery of Joe Manchin
is the guy standing in the way not only generally
of an infrastructure bill and a spending bill
as big as what many Democrats and Joe Biden
want.
It's not just that Joe Manchin is generally
standing in the way.
Joe Manchin is standing in the way.
Of West Virginians who are his constituents
from getting that, who so desperately need
it and talking about it from the back of his
yacht.
OK, you can't have more insidious imagery
than this, and I hate to say this.
West Virginia is a disaster.
I'm not going after the people of West Virginia.
What I'm telling you is West Virginia needs
this.
West Virginia is ranked 47th out of 50 in
health care in terms of access, quality and
public health.
47 out of 50 50 is the worst, not the best.
Just to be clear, West Virginia is ranked
45th out of 50 in terms of education.
As far as higher ED and pre-K through 12 are
concerned as far as infrastructure.
West Virginia is dead last 50th out of 50
American states.
That's based on energy, internet access and
transportation, so I could go on and on.
But the point is that West Virginia is one
of the states that most desperately needs
this spending.
Spending education, health care and hilariously
or maybe not hilariously, maybe it's more
a tragedy.
West Virginia is one of the biggest takers
if states had welfare queens.
It's not a term that I actually believe in.
You know it has.
It's an old trope from Reagan, but in any
case, if states had welfare queens.
West Virginia is one of the biggest welfare
queens.
West Virginia is the fifth most dependent
state on money from the federal government.
Big, strong, independent.
No, actually, they are highly dependent on
federal money, and this is the guy that they
have from his yacht saying, Oh, we don't need
to do that yet, and maybe we'll get to this.
Or maybe, maybe we will get to that.
West Virginia is not well served by Joe Manchin.
The country is not well-served by Joe Manchin.
But yet I'm not going to forget the reality.
You all know that I'm also a pragmatist.
If you primary Joe Manchin with Bernie and
somehow Bernie wins among Democrats in West
Virginia.
Then you get a Republican in that seat.
And so we we are in this conundrum, and I
continue to believe really the path forward
is if Manchin has to be if mentions the Democrat
that we can get in West Virginia, then there
need to be other seats won from other states
that are more moderate.
I'd sure taken all of the above approach.
I'm not saying don't do that, but we often
end up in that conundrum.
We're going to have more of this clip of Manchin
addressing the peons from his yacht on our
Instagram.
You can find us at David Pakman show on Instagram.
Find me on Instagram at David Pakman.